IS GOING TO BE OUR LIVE GUEST AS
WE CONTINUE TO LIVE FROM DETROI
DETROIT.
>> Laura: ROCK STAR PANEL
TONIGHT, WE'VE GOT REINCE
PRIEBUS, FORMER WHITE HOUSE
CHIEF OF STAFF.
BYRON YORK,
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER," FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
AND DENNIS KUCINICH, FORMER
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN AND
FORMER 2008 CANDIDATE.
HARVEY DILLON IS WITH US, TRUMP
ADVISORY BOARD MEMBER.
WHAT ARE PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
ALLIES THINKING TONIGHT WATCHING
WHAT HAPPENED IN THIS SECOND
DEMOCRATIC DEBATE?
>> AS I WAS WATCHING IT, I
THOUGHT THEY WERE TO GO
STATEMENTS TO MAKE THEIR
PRESIDENT TRUMP VERY CLEARLY
BECAUSE, NUMBER ONE, DEMOCRATS
ARE DEBATING THROWING OFF
200 MILLION PEOPLE OFF PRIVATE
INSURANCE.
THEY ARE TRASHING BARACK OBAMA,
TALKING ABOUT MEDICARE FOR ALL,
ANOTHER 32 TRILLION.
THE SECOND WINNER IS JOE BIDEN
BECAUSE ONE THING I LEARNED IN
2016 IS WHEN IT WAS ALL TRUMP
ALL THE TIME COME ON THE MATTER
GOOD, BAD, IN THE MIDDLE, TRUMP
ALWAYS WON IN THAT BATTLE.
ALL ABOUT JOE BIDEN, CONSTANTLY
ATTACKING HIM, IT WAS ALL ABOUT
BIDEN.
PLUS 20 GOING INTO THE DEBATE.
IF ANYTHING HE WAS HELPED BY THE
DEBATE AND ULTIMATELY IT WAS A
GOOD NIGHT FOR HIM AND A GREAT
NIGHT FOR THE PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: BYRON, WHAT STOOD
OUT WHEN I WATCH THE THING IS MY
GOODNESS, IF BARACK OBAMA SHOWED
UP ON STAGE, HE WOULD BE ONE OF
THE MORE CONSERVATIVE PEOPLE ON
THAT STAGE.
THEY WOULD HAVE TO ATTACK HIM
STANDING RIGHT THERE.
THIS WAS AMAZING TO SEE, THE
PARTY OF DOOM AND GLOOM, PRETTY
MUCH EVERYONE WAS DOOM AND GLOOM
INSTEAD OF BIDEN WHO SAID, ELECT
ME AND WE ARE GOING TO DO OBAMA
3.0.
>> HE'S ALWAYS BEEN THE
CANDIDATE OF RESTORATION.
THERE ARE CANDIDATES OF
TRANSFORMATION, HE'S THE
CANDIDATE OF RESTORATION.
WATCHING THIS, IF YOU ARE A
DEMOCRAT AND YOU TRULY THINK THE
HOUSE IS ON FIRE, WE ARE IN A
BIG EMERGENCY BECAUSE OF
DONALD TRUMP, THE DEBATE STARTED
OUT WITH 40 MINUTES OF ARCANE
DISCUSSION OF HEALTH CARE IN
WHICH THEY DID DISCUSS WHETHER
OR NOT TO TAKE AWAY PEOPLE'S
PRIVATE INSURANCE, CAME TO NO
PARTICULAR CONCLUSION, AND
NOBODY GAVE THAT SENTENCE OF
EMERGENCY THAT THE DEMOCRATIC
BASE IS FEELING FOR THEY WEREN'T
SEEING IT IN THEIR CANDIDATES.
>> Laura: DENNIS KUCINICH, YOU
ARGUED A LOT OF THESE ISSUES IN
THE PAST THAT YOU HAVE TO TAKE
ON THE BIG DOGS IN YOUR PARTY IN
ORDER TO BE A TRANSFORMATIONAL
CANDIDATE.
BUT TONIGHT, IT WAS IN AWE THE
THING TO WATCH BECAUSE, AGAIN,
BARACK OBAMA A TWO TERM
PRESIDENT, EXTREMELY POPULAR.
GLOBAL SUPERSTAR, BUT PRETTY
MUCH ALL OF THEM WERE HITTING
OBAMA WITHOUT NECESSARILY SAYING
IT.
OBAMACARE, TRADE DEALS, THEY DID
IT LAST NIGHT TOO.
BIDEN IS THERE SAYING IT, THAT
WAS THE PARTY OF HOPE AND
CHANGE.
>> THERE IS A COUPLE OF THINGS
HERE.
FIRST OF ALL, WE HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT SOME OF THE
DEFICIENCIES OF THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION CREATED THE
OPENING OF DONALD TRUMP.
AS FAR AS HEALTH CARE, THERE IS
A REAL DIVIDE AMONG DEMOCRATS ON
HEALTH CARE AND THERE HAS BEEN
FOR DECADES.
IN 2000, I WENT TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PLATFORM'S COMMITTEE
TO PRESENT MEDICARE FOR ALL AND
IT WAS SHOT DOWN BY THE GORE
CAMPAIGN.
AND THE SUPPORT FOR MEDICARE OR
FOR ALL IS GROWING.
YOU WOULDN'T KNOW IT BY
TONIGHT'S DEBATE, YOU WOULD KNOW
IT FROM YESTERDAYS WITH
BERNIE SANDERS.
>> Laura: WE HAD THE LANING
FOR JOHN DELANEY THE ONLY ONE
WITH BUSINESS EXPERIENCE OTHER
THAN ANDREW YANG.
I RAN TWO HEALTH CARE
COMPANIES -- MEDICARE PAYS 80%
FOR WHAT DOCTORS NEED TO COVER
THEIR COSTS.
MEDICARE FOR ALL WILL CRATER
WHATEVER IT'S GOING TO CRATER,
WHICH IS MEDICARE BUT WE'VE GOT
KAMALA AND THEY ARE MIXING IT UP
IN THE BEGINNING OVER THIS
MEDICARE FOR ALL CONVERSATION.
IT'S HARD TO FOLLOW FOR MOST
PEOPLE WHO DON'T KNOW THE ISSUES
FOR THIS IS HOW IT WENT DOWN.
>> VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
CAMPAIGN CALLED YOUR PLAN "A
HAVE IT EVERY WHICH WAY
APPROACH" AND ITS "PART OF THE
CONFUSING PATTER DOWN THE
PATTERN OF EQUIVOCATING YOUR
HEALTH CARE STANDS."
>> HE'S PROBABLY CONFUSE HE'S
NOT LISTENING.
>> YOU SHOULD GET SOMETHING GOOD
IN TEN YEARS, YOU SHOULD WONDER
WHY IT TAKES TEN YEARS BUT IT
WILL REQUIRE MIDDLE-CLASS TAXES
TO GO UP, NOT DOWN.
>> THE COST OF DOING NOTHING IS
FAR TOO EXPENSIVE.
>> Laura: DID JOE BIDEN WIN
THAT EXCHANGE?
>> I THINK HE POINTED OUT THAT
KAMALA HARRIS IS ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
HE COULD'VE POINTED OUT THAT
BERNIE'S PLAN ELIMINATES PRIVATE
HEALTH CARE ALTOGETHER.
HE JUST CAME OUT AND SET IT AND
OWNED IT.
KAMALA HARRIS' A PROBLEM AS I
WROTE IN A "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
OP-ED ISSUE FLIP-FLOPPED ON
EVERY SINGLE ISSUE.
SHE WANTS TO HAVE IT EVERY
SINGLE WAY.
EVERY 30 MINUTES OF DISCUSSION
AND HER HAVING FIVE TIMES THE
AIRTIME OF THE OTHER CANDIDATES,
SHE STILL WOULDN'T SAY HOW MUCH
IT'S GOING TO COST AND WHAT IT
REALLY ACCOMPLISHES BIT I DO
THINK BIDEN DID A BETTER JOB IN
THAT EXCHANGE THEN KAMALA
HARRIS.
>> I WOULD HAVE TO AGREE AND
THAT SENATOR HARRIS HAS BEEN ALL
OVER THE MAP.
HER PROPOSAL ON THE SO-CALLED
MEDICARE FOR ALL REALLY ISN'T.
IT LOOKS LIKE A DUCK, BUT IT
QUACKS LIKE AN INSURANCE COMPAN
COMPANY.
>> Laura: OKAY.
BY WRITTEN, THE MOST UPSETTING
BLOW TO HARRIS, AGAIN, WHO WAS
BUILT UP MUCH LIKE BETO O'ROURKE
WAS BUILT UP, BUTTIGIEG WAS
BUILT UP, THAT IT WAS HARRIS,
SHE'S BEEN BUILT UP FOR WEEKS
AND WEEKS AND WEEKS, THIS WAS
ANOTHER MOMENT FOR HER TO SHINE.
THIS WAS THE MOST DEVASTATING
BLOW TO HER.
WATCH.
>> SHE PUT OVER 1500 PEOPLE IN
JAIL FOR MARIJUANA VIOLATIONS
AND LAUGHED ABOUT IT WHEN SHE
WAS ASKED IF SHE EVER SMOKED
MARIJUANA.
EVIDENCE THAT WOULD'VE FREED AN
INNOCENT MAN FROM DEATH ROW
UNTIL THE COURTS FORCE HER TO DO
SO.
SHE KEPT PEOPLE IN PRISON BEYOND
THEIR SENTENCES TO USE HAVE THEM
AS CHEAP LABOR IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THERE IS NO EXCUSE FOR THAT AND
THE PEOPLE WHO SUFFERED UNDER
URANUS PROSECUTOR, YOU OWE THEM
AN APOLOGY.
>> Laura: SHE ANSWERED NO,
THAT'S NOT TRUE, BUT I DO NOT
KNOW WHO IS GOING TO FACT-CHECK
KAMALA HARRIS.
THAT MIGHT WORK IN THE GENERAL
FOR A KAMALA HARRIS.
SHE'S TOUGH ON CRIME.
IN THIS PRIMARY IN THIS
TEMPERATURE, DOES THAT WORK?
>> IT DOESN'T WORK.
YOU CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
ALSO, THESE CANDIDATES THAT ARE
NOT KAMALA HARRIS AND NOT
JOE BIDEN, THEY ARE PREPARING,
PREPARING FOR THESE ATTACKS.
TULSI GABBARD WENT THEY ARE
READY TO ATTACK KAMALA HARRIS
BECAUSE SHE'S IN THE SECOND
POSITION.
THESE OTHER CANDIDATES ARE ON
THE ATTACK.
HERE IS ONE THING THAT REMINDS
ME OF 2016, THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN 2016 AND NOW.
THE ONE THING DEMOCRATS ARE
GETTING RIGHT THE REST OF THE
FIELD IS THEY ARE ALL ATTACKING
BIDEN.
ALL TRYING TO TAKE HIM DOWN BUT
IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK RIGHT NOW
BUT THEY ARE ALL ATTACKING HIM.
2016, THE REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES
DID NOT ATTACK DONALD TRUMP.
THEY WERE AFRAID TO ATTACK
DONALD TRUMP.
THEY ONLY ATTACKED EACH OTHER,
NOT EACH OTHER OUT OF THE GAME
AND TRUMP WAS STANDING THERE AND
AFRAID TO GO AFTER HIM.
THEY ARE NOT AFRAID TO GO AFTER
JOE BIDEN.
THEY KNOW THAT IF THEY DON'T
KNOCK HIM DOWN A COUPLE OF
NOTCHES WITHIN THE NEXT TWO
MONTHS, THINGS WILL BE VERY
DIFFICULT BIT I ALSO THINK THE
DNC IS ON THE BRINK OF LOSING
COMPLETE CONTROL
OVER THIS PRIMARY.
>> Laura: EXPLAIN THIS TO US.
IMPORTANT POINT THAT EVERYBODY
NEEDS TO LISTEN TO WHAT REINCE
PRIEBUS TELMEX IS SAYING.
>> ONCE THE FIELD STARTS TO
NARROW, IT TAKES NOTHING -- IF
CNN WANTS TO DO A DEBATE EVERY
SINGLE NIGHT WITH SEVEN OF THESE
CANDIDATES, THEY CAN GET THREE
TIMES A VIEWERSHIP.
IF YOU ARE 1% IN IOWA, WE ARE
ALL 1% IN IOWA, LARA IS AT 30%.
>> Laura: EXACTLY.
>> WHY WOULD WE NOT HAVE A
DEBATE EVERY NIGHT ON CNN, THE
THREE OF US, TO CATCH UP?
THE REASON THE DNC NEEDS TO GET
CONTROL IS THESE 19, 18, 15
CANDIDATES ARE GOING TO GO ON
THEIR OWN, GO ROGUE, AND THIS IS
ABOUT TO BREAK LOOSE.
I THINK YOU ARE SEEING THIS
START.
>> Laura: BYRON, INTERESTING.
I LIKE THE INJURY, PALACE
INTRIGUE AT THE DNC.
>> THIS IS THE LAST TIME YOU'LL
SEE MOST OF THESE CANDIDATES ON
STAGE IN THE DEBATE.
THE RULES CHANGE THE NEXT TIME.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE TO QUALIFY FOR
THE DEBATE AT LEAST 2% IN THE
POLLS, EITHER NATIONALLY OR IN
THE NUMBER OF STAPLES.
RIGHT NOW, SIX OR SEVEN
MEMBERS --
B1 LET'S GET SOME
TELMEX BE ONE WHO WOULD YOU
THINK ARE NOT GOING TO MAKE IT?
>> THE ONES WHO STAY IN ARE THE
TOP FOUR, BERNIE, BIDEN, HARRIS.
WARREN, BOOKER MAY BE,
BUTTIGIEG.
THAT'S ABOUT IT.
THE REST OF THEM ARE GOING AWAY.
>> Laura: YOUR POINT IS THAT
THEY CAN STILL POP UP ON CNN.
>> WHAT'S TO STOP TEN OF THESE
CANDIDATES IF THEY GET KNOCKED
OUT?
WHAT'S TO STOP THOSE TEN FROM
DOING A DEBATE ON CNN?
>> THEY HAVE NOT TIED TO DEBATE
CALENDAR TO THE NOMINATION
PROCESS.
>> Laura: I GET WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING.
>> THEY HAVE NOT TIED IT TO THE
RULE OF THE NOMINATION.
IT'S A FREE-FOR-ALL.
>> Laura: DENNIS KUCINICH, YOU
AND I TALKED ABOUT THIS BEFORE
THE SHOW BEGAN.
I KEEP THINKING ABOUT THE
GUYS -- THEY COULD BE GUYS OR
GALS, WHO ARE MASTER
CAMPAIGNERS.
BARACK OBAMA, BILL CLINTON,
DONALD TRUMP, GEORGE W. BUSH.
THAT'S NOT BECAUSE THEY WON, BUT
THEY WERE PHENOMENAL RETAIL
POLITICIANS.
WHO ON THAT STAGE TONIGHT, OTHER
THAN BIDEN, HAS THAT KIND OF
COMMON TOUCH?
CAN BE A LITTLE
SELF-DEPRECATING.
CAN THE SLUR HIS WORDS EVERY NOW
AND THEN.
I DO NOT THINK ANYONE CARES
ABOUT THAT.
WHO COMES CLOSE TO A RETAIL
POLITICIAN WITH SOME PIZZAZZ?
I DIDN'T SEE IT.
I TRY TO LOOK AT IT AS AN
ANALYST.
I DID NOT SEE THAT KIND OF
OBAMA/TRUMP GO GET IT.
I DIDN'T SEE IT.
>> IT'S STILL EARLY.
>> Laura: MARIANNE WILLIAMSON,
MAY BE.
>> IT STILL EARLY IN THE
CAMPAIGN.
AND YOU CAN'T SPEAK ELECTED TO
SOME OF THE OFFICE THESE PEOPLE
HOLD WITHOUT HAVING SOME SKILL
AT RETAIL.
I WOULD NOT WRITE ANYBODY OFF
RIGHT NOW.
ALTHOUGH IT'S TRUE A
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE CAN
DETERMINE IF SOMEONE'S GOING TO
BE VISIBLE TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, THERE IS STILL A LOT OF
MOVEMENT.
AGAIN, TONIGHT -- YOU PICKED IT
UP.
TULSI GABBARD, FOR EXAMPLE.
THAT EXCHANGE SHE HAD WITH --
B1 IT SHOWS HER VULNERABILITY.
KAMALA HARRIS' VULNERABILITY.
IF YOU CAN'T ANSWER TULSI
GABBARD -- I LIKE TULSI GABBARD.
YOU THINK YOU ARE GOING TO GO
TOE-TO-TOE WITH TRUMP?
>> A PROSECUTOR IS GOOD ON
OFFENSE AND SHE'S GOOD ON
OFFENSE.
BUT SENATOR HARRIS DIDN'T DO
WELL ON DEFENSE.
>> Laura: DEMOCRATS HAVE A NEW
PHRASE.
WE CAN'T ANSWER OR DON'T WANT TO
ANSWER THIS QUESTION.
WATCH.
>> STOPPED USING REPUBLICAN
TALKING POINTS IN ORDER TO TALK
WITH EACH OTHER ABOUT HOW TO
BEST PROVIDE HEALTH CARE.
>> YOUR QUESTION IS A REPUBLICAN
TALKING POINT!
>> WE CANNOT KEEP WITH
REPUBLICAN TALKING POINTS ON
THIS.
YOU'VE GOT TO STOP.
>> OPEN BORDERS IS A RIGHT WING
TALKING POINT.
>> Laura: THAT'S A CUTE TRICK,
ISN'T IT?
>> IT'S LAME WHEN YOU HEAR IT
AGAIN AND AGAIN.
WHAT THEY DO NOT LIKE IS THE
REPUBLICAN REALITY OUTSIDE THAT
ROOM.
THE REALITY THAT DONALD TRUMP
HAS BEEN THE BEST PRESIDENT EVER
FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM,
WHICH IS SOMETHING,
AFRICAN-AMERICAN JOBS, RISING
TIDE FOR ALL AMERICANS, FOR
EVERYTHING IN OUR ECONOMY.
THEY DO NOT LIKE THOSE FACTS.
THEY ARE PAINTING AND CONJURING
A PICTURE OF THIS DYSTOPIAN
AMERICA WHERE THE SEAS ARE
RISING, WE ARE SHIVERING IN THE
HUDDLES AND CAGES IN THE
STREETS.
I DO NOT THINK IT'S WORKING.
IT'S VERY FAKE.
LAURA, YOU ARE POINTING TO THIS.
MOST OF THESE CANDIDATES ARE
TOTALLY FAKE.
KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND, THANKS FOR
PLAYING.
GO INTO OHIO AND EXPLAIN
WHITENESS TO WHITE WOMEN?
WHAT IS THAT?
IT'S CRAZY.
I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT, BIDEN IS
THE ONLY ONE AUTHENTIC BUT HE'S
GOT HIS OWN PROBLEMS.
I ACTUALLY THINK HE IMPROVED
FROM THE LAST DEBATE.
>> Laura: THIS IS A NIGHTMARE
FOR HARRIS TONIGHT.
WE HAVEN'T EVEN GOTTEN TO THE
TRADE STUFF, WHAT HAPPENED ON
IMMIGRATION.
CASTRO EMBARRASSED HIMSELF ON
TO THAT POINT HOW BIDEN
POSITIONS HIMSELF, I THINK HE
ROSE ABOVE ALL OF THIS.
HE WAS UP THERE DEFENDING
OBAMACARE.
ALL THE REST OF THE PEOPLE ARE
TRASHING OBAMACARE.
>> NOT A GREAT PLACE TO BE
EITHER WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Laura: IT'S FAIRLY POPULAR.
>> IT'S BETTER THAN GREEN NEW
DEAL AND MEDICARE FOR ALL.
HERE'S THE ISSUE YOU HIT ON.
THE PROBLEM DEMOCRATS HAVE, ALL
THESE POSITIONS COME IN GREEN
NEW DEAL, MEDICARE FOR ALL,
REPARATIONS, JOB SECURITY,
MANDATORY PAID VACATION, HOW
DOES THAT PLAY OUT IN
PITTSBURGH, MILWAUKEE, COLUMBUS,
CLEVELAND, WHAT DO THOSE PEOPLE
THINK OF THOSE POSITIONS?
IT DOESN'T WORK.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT, I THINK
CORY BOOKER SAID SOMETHING ABOUT
THE PARIS CLAIMANT ACCORDS BEING
CHILD'S PLAY.
>> Laura: A NO-BRAINER.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID IT WELL
WHEN HE SAID WE ARE ABOUT
PITTSBURGH, NOT PARIS.
TRUMP WINS THAT ARGUMENT EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
THEY CAN HAVE THEIR DEBATE AS
BYRON OPENED UP.
THEY CAN HAVE THIS ESOTERIC
DEBATE.
BUT IN THE END, IT'S THE
POSITIONS OF THIS PRESIDENT THAT
IS GOING TO HELP THEM WIN IN THE
MIDWEST AND THESE POSITIONS ARE
GOING TO KILL THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY.
>> Laura: SPEW ENVIRON,A
>> Laura: SPEW ENVIRON,D
>> Laura: SPEW ENVIRON,L
>> Laura: SPEW ENVIRON,T
>> Laura: SPEW ENVIRON,O
>> Laura: SPEW ENVIRON,F
>> Laura: SPEW ENVIRON,M
>> Laura: SPEW ENVIRON,N
>> Laura: SPEW ENVIRON,Y
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
>> Laura: TRILLIONS AND
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS, ANYBODY
WHO WANTS TO COME IN WHEN YOU
BOIL IT ALL DAY
DOWN, UNLESS YOU'RE A MURDERER,
BUT IF YOU SHOW UP YOU ARE GOING
TO STAY.
WE WILL DIE IN 12 YEARS.
CLIMATE CHANGE, RISING SEAS,
FLINT, MICHIGAN, SEGREGATION IN
THE '70s, RELITIGATING BUSING.
THIS SEEMS LIKE A TOTAL
DISCONNECT WHAT YOU WILL,
DENNIS KUCINICH, TALKING ABOUT
YOUR WHOLE LIFE.
RENTS PREVIOUS FROM THE MIDWEST,
THE RUST BELT IS WHERE THIS
ELECTION WILL BE WON OR LOST IN
MY VIEW.
>> LAST NIGHT WAS A MORE
PROGRESSIVE CROWD IN IMMIGRATION
FOR THE LAST DEBATE THEY ALL
RAISED THEIR HANDS AND SAID THEY
WERE IN FAVOR OF
D DECRIMINALIZING ILLEGAL BORDER
D DECRIMINALIZING ILLEGAL BORDEC
D DECRIMINALIZING ILLEGAL BORDEO
D DECRIMINALIZING ILLEGAL BORDES
D DECRIMINALIZING ILLEGAL BORDEN
D DECRIMINALIZING ILLEGAL BORDE.
LAST DON'T LIKE
TONIGHT YOU HAD JOE BIDEN SAYING
THAT IT'S ILLEGAL TO CROSS THE
BORDER ILLEGALLY.
HE IS NOT IN THE MAJORITY.
ALL OF THIS IS GOING TO BE ON
THE RECORD SO THEY ALL CAME OUT
AND SAY WE ARE IN FAVOR OF
EFFECTIVE OPEN BORDERS.
THEY CAN TRY TO CHANGE THAT WHEN
THE GENERAL ELECTION COMES
AROUND THAT WE'VE ALREADY SEEN
IT.
>> Laura: LATER ON, WE'LL TALK
ABOUT HOW DE BLASIO THREE TIMES
TRIED TO TAKE OUT JOE BIDEN ON
THE ISSUE OF IMMIGRATION.
HE WENT THREE TIMES TO BITE AT
THE APPLE OF DEPORTATION WHICH
AGAIN, DENNIS, I KNOW YOU ARE
MORE PROGRESSIVE THAN SOME OF
THESE MIDWEST CENTRIST
DEMOCRATS, BUT YOU STILL HAVE TO
PUT TOGETHER THAT ELECTORAL
MATH.
HOW DO YOU PUT THE ELECTORAL
MATH TOGETHER WHEN IT'S
BASICALLY OPEN BORDERS, AND LESS
SPENDING, GUARANTEED INCOMES,
REPARATIONS, GREEN NEW DEAL,
MEDICARE FOR ALL.
>> Laura: I WOULD PRESENTED IN
A DIFFERENT PACKAGE BUT I WOULD
SAY MEDICARE FOR ALL MANDATORY.
I THINK THEY CAN WIN ON THAT.
I ALSO THINK YOU CAN WIN ON JOBS
AND WAGES.
>> Laura: 99% OF AMERICA HAS
SEEN A WAGE INCREASE.
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" PIECE
TODAY WAS DEVASTATING ON THAT.
99% OF AMERICANS HAVE SEEN THEIR
WAGES BASICALLY GO UP.
BIG SCREAMING HEADLINE IN THE
JOURNAL TODAY.
>> THE QUESTION IS BY WHAT
DEGREE.
>> Laura: MORE THAN UNDER
OBAMA.
>> LOOK, I'M NOT ARGUING ABOUT
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION HERE
VERSUS THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
I AM SPEAKING IN A RELATIVE
SENSE WHETHER OR NOT THERE IS
HOPE FOR PARTICULARLY
WORKING-CLASS PEOPLE IN OHIO WHO
HAVE BEEN SHUT OUT OF A LOT OF
THE GAINS IN THE ECONOMY.
>> Laura: DOES ANYBODY ON THAT
STAGE REALLY THINK THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO DO A BETTER JOB AT
CREATING JOBS THAN DONALD TRUMP
OR THEY ARE GOING TO DO A BETTER
JOB AT HEALTH CARE REFORM THAN
BARACK OBAMA?
>> I DON'T SEE IT --
>> WHERE IT IS IS REBUILD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> Laura: THE DEMOCRATS DON'T
WANT TO BUILD THE INFRASTRUCTUR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> LAURA, HUGE MISTAKE.
>> Laura: CASTOR ARGUING THIS
IS NOT A GOOD ECONOMY TONIGHT.
>> THAT'S RIDICULOUS FOR THEY
WOULD HAVE NOTHING TO COMPLAIN
ABOUT.
THEY WOULD HAVE TO DEMONIZE THE
PRESIDENT, WHICH IS GETTING VERY
TIRED.
NOT TALKING ABOUT SOLUTIONS FOR
AMERICANS, THEY HAVE A
COMPLETELY ALTERED VIEW OF
REALITY.
OTHER COUNTRIES CAN COME IN AND
STAY HERE BUT THE TAXPAYERS ARE
GOING TO PAY FOR IT.
WITH WHAT MONEY?
THEY REALLY FAIL AT THAT, AND
WHEN IT COMES TO DONALD TRUMP
GETTING UP AGAINST ANY OF THESE,
THEY CAN'T WAIT TO SEE IT.
AND NOT GOING TO SEE IT AS MANY
OF THE OTHER GUEST HAVE POINTED
OUT TONIGHT, MOST OF THESE
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO TAKE THE
CONSOLATION PRIZE AND GO FOR THE
MOST PART.
BUT I DO NOT SEE HOW MANY OF
THEM ARE GOING TO DO BETTER THAN
TRUMP ON A LOT OF THE ISSUES
THEY TALKED ABOUT.
BIDEN, THE LEADING CANDIDATE, HE
TOOK SOME HITS FOR THE FACT THAT
HIS ADMINISTRATION HAD DEPORTED
MANY.
>> Laura: I DO WANT TO GET
BACK TO WHAT I MENTIONED,
HITTING BIDEN, OTHER 2020 DEMS
ALSO PILED ON THE PRESIDENT,
OBAMA'S LEGACY.
>> THE ISSUE CAME UP WITH ALL
THOSE DEPORTATIONS, YOU ARE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, I DIDN'T HEAR
WHETHER YOU'D STOP THEM OR NOT
USING YOUR POWER, INFLUENCE IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> THE PRESIDENT CAME ALONG AND
SAID HE'S THE GUY WHO CAME UP
WITH A DREAMER DREAMERS.
COMPARING HIM TO DONALD TRUMP I
THINK IS ABSOLUTELY BIZARRE.
>> I DO NOT HEAR AN ANSWER FROM
THE VICE PRESIDENT.
>> HE MOVED TO FIGHT MENTALLY
CHANGE THE SYSTEM.
>> MR. VICE PRESIDENT, YOU CAN
HAVE
CANNOT HAVE IT BOTH WAYS BUT YOU
CAN'T DODGE IT WHEN IT'S NOT.
>> Laura: PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD
A LOT OF DEPORTATION SO THE
CONCLUSION IS THAT OBAMA WAS TOO
CONSERVATIVE FOR THIS DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
>> IT'S A TOUGH SELL IN THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY AND THAT'S WHY
BIDEN IS 20 POINTS UP.
BIDEN HAS TO BE CAREFUL HERE.
THE PARTY, ME AND OTHERS -- IT'S
EASY FOR US TO DISMISS THIS
ENTIRE FIELD AS COMPLETELY
WACKO, BUT THE ONE GUY THAT IS
NOT NECESSARILY IN THAT CATEGORY
IS PLUS 20 OVER THE REST.
SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE PARTY TO FOCUS IN ON
JOE BIDEN, TALK ABOUT THE FACT
THAT HE'S FOR THE GREEN NEW
DEAL.
HE CAME OUT IN FAVOR OF IT.
93 TRILLION -- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE DON'T LOSE
SIGHT OF THAT.
I THINK THAT BARACK OBAMA IS FAR
TOO POPULAR STILL WITHIN
DEMOCRAT BAYS.
IT'S MUCH DIFFERENT THAN BUSH IN
'08 AND 2010 WHEN YOU HAD CRUZ
AND MIKE LEE
END.
>> Laura: 65% OF DEMOCRATS
WANT TO CONTINUE OBAMA'S LEGACY.
>> I DO NOT THINK BIDEN LAID TO
REST CONCERNS ABOUT HIS AGE,
ABOUT HIS SHARPNESS.
THERE WAS ENOUGH HALTING THIS IN
HIS PERFORMANCE.
DIFFICULTIES IN FORMULATING
IDEAS.
I DO NOT THINK THIS IS GOING
AWAY AND THE AGENT IS GOING TO
BE A PROBLEM FROM NOW ON FOR HIM
BE A PROBLEM FROM NOW ON FOR HI.
>> I WOULD HAVE TO AGREE WITH
BYRON TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
VICE PRESIDENT SEEMS TO
INTERRUPT HIMSELF A FEW TIMES.
HE BROKE THE FLOW OF HIS OWN
PRESENTATION WHICH DIDN'T HELP
THEM.
I ALSO THINK THAT CORY BOOKER
DID A PRETTY GOOD JOB IN PUTTING
THE VICE PRESIDENT TO THE TEST.
>> Laura: WAS CORY BOOKER NOT
CATCHING ON
WHY IS CORY BOOKER NOT CATCHING
ON?
HE'S ARTICULATE, WE WERE ARGUING
NEWARK POLICE POLICY.
WE WERE ARGUING NYPD, WE ARE
ARGUING NEW WORK, THEN WE ARE
ARGUING -- IT SEEMS LIKE, NOT
SAYING IT'S NOT IMPORTANT,
BUT FOR A DEMOCRAT PRIMARY, IT
SEEMED TO REALLY GRANULAR.
I THINK MOST OF IT WENT OVER
PEOPLE'S HEADS.
>> EVEN IF YOU DO NOT GET IT TO
THE GRANULAR ASPECTS OF IT,
BIDEN HAD GOOD POINTS HOW HE
LIED AND THE ACLU ACCUSED BOOKER
AND ET CETERA.
COMES ACROSS, IF YOU TURN THE
VOLUME AND LOOK AT THE BODY
LANGUAGE, COMES ACROSS AS VERY
SHRILL, HYPER, IN-YOUR-FACE, WE
SAW THAT IN THE KAVANAUGH
HEARINGS, SEE THAT IN ALL OF HIS
PERFORMANCES OVERALL.
IT'S UP AT 11, THIS IS SPINAL
TAP, THIS ONE NOTE AND IT'S TOO
MUCH.
PEOPLE DON'T WANT THAT.
I THINK THEY WANT A BIDEN THAT'S
FUNCTIONING FOR THAT'S WHAT IS
THE PROBLEM.
BIDEN HALTING, THE KIND OF MINI